another day another impeachment witness
affirms that president Trump committed
no quid pro quo with Ukraine of course
you wouldn't know that from the front
pages of the New York Times in the
Washington Post
we will parse the spin and lies then
speaking of spin and lies the Democrats
returned to the stage for this month's
presidential primary debate and I
watched every agonizing moment of it a
high school girl cries after her school
district forces her to undress in front
of boys progress and finally the mailbag
all that and more I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
okay here's what you've read in the
newspapers today
well you haven't because you don't read
the New York Times in the Washington
Post because you are an educated person
but this is what most people are reading
in the newspapers today New York Times
Sandlin says he followed Trump's orders
the Washington Post sundaland links
Trump administration to pressure
campaign on Ukraine diplomat says there
was a quid pro quo a White House meeting
if Ukraine opened probes into Joe Biden
sand lands bombshell testimony leaves
Trump's GOP allies scrambling scrambling
they are like scurrying like mice on
Capitol Hill of course none of that is
true none of that is true if you read
those headlines what you would conclude
from that is that Trump engaged in a
quid pro quo whatever that is that's
been that's been the latest accusation
that they've hurled at Trump really all
we've had for this whole impeachment
probe is that there's been sort of
nebulous wrongdoing no one can point to
a crime nobody can point to a high crime
or misdemeanor but they just he did
something wrong he's got to leave office
that if you read those headlines it
would be impossible not to conclude that
Trump committed an impeachable offense
unless you had greater context or unless
you had actually watched the testimony
so let's let's look at it unvarnished no
interpretive lens of the mainstream
media what did Gordon sunland the big
ambassador to the European Union the big
witness yesterday for the Democrats what
did Santa land actually say about Trump
he said repeatedly and explicitly that
Trump told him not to engage in a quid
pro quo with Ukraine here is my
testimony is I never heard from
President Trump that aid was conditioned
on an announcement of elections so you
never heard those specific words correct
right but never heard those words again
I don't recall president Trump ever
talking to me about any security
assistance ever
did the president ever tell you
personally about any preconditions for
anything no okay so the president never
told you about any preconditions for the
aid to be released no the president
never told you about any preconditions
for a White House meeting personally no
but I believe I just asked him an
open-ended question mr. chairman what do
you want from Ukraine I keep hearing all
these different ideas and theories and
this and that what do you want and it
was a very short abrupt conversation he
was not in a good mood and he just said
I want nothing I want nothing I want no
quid pro quo televizzle Lensky to do the
right thing something to that effect
that last clip by the way was to Adam
Schiff who's running this whole charade
and Adam Schiff is just there devastated
he is obviously crestfallen the only
contradiction in there worth noting is
that at the very beginning of the clip
sunland said I never heard those words
quid pro quo from the president and then
later on he says I actually did hear
those words when later he told me
explicitly do not engage in a quid pro
quo I do not want a quid pro quo so
that's it right that's it
that's the whole thing the Democrats at
least in the latest iteration obviously
they've been trying to impeach him for
three years but the latest version is
Trump committed a quid pro quo no
evidence of that a quid pro quo is an
impeachable offense no evidence of that
therefore we need to remove President
Trump from office okay if that's the
Democrats argument then you just heard
from the guy from the ambassador to the
European Union Gordon Sunland Trump told
me explicitly do not engage in a quid
pro quo and that was only after I
testified that we didn't even talk about
consider tea concerns we didn't even
talk about the aid but then when the aid
was brought up he said do not engage in
a quid pro quo so that's it it's over
right okay that's that would be the
conclusion of any reasonable person so
what's the conclusion of Democrat Adam
Schiff here he is because I think
today's testimony is among the most
significant
evidence to date and what we have just
heard from ambassador Sunland is that
the knowledge of this scheme this
conditioning of the White House meeting
of the security assistance to get the
deliverable the president wanted these
two political investigations that he
believed would help his reelection
campaign was a basic quid pro quo that's
your conclusion that's your conclusion
after after he says Trump never told me
to engage in a quid pro quo
I never heard those words we never
discussed security assistance there
never were preconditions for the White
House meeting and oh by the way he told
me explicitly no quid pro quo your
conclusion is yeah there was basically a
quid pro quo basically when you really
think about it when you really look deep
deep down it looks like there was a quid
pro quo he's lying right to your face
Adam chef Adam Schiff is going on
television and what he is relying on is
that no one is watching the testimony
itself what he's relying on is that no
one's gonna play those clips so that you
hear it unvarnished what he's hoping is
that people are just gonna watch clips
of politicians talking about the
testimony on CNN and for most people
that's true Adam Schiff is not a stupid
man
Adam Schiff realizes that the majority
of Americans are not paying attention to
this a huge number of American Lincoln's
like 35% haven't heard anything about
the impeachment they don't read about it
they don't hear about it on television
so he is going to try to convey his
narrative which contradicts reality now
he did get one good clipping yesterday
we will examine that and see if that
gives an ultimate PR win for Democrats
if they can if they can keep this hoax
going on a little bit longer but first
speaking of security assistance we have
got to thank our friends over a ring who
helped make home security so so safe
this season can be a whirlwind of
deliveries and visitors and holiday
travel so it's the best time of the year
to upgrade your doorbell and you can
keep an eye on your home from anywhere
in the country whether you're in your
bedroom or whether you're at Grandma's
house
across the continent no matter where the
holidays take you ring helps you stay
connected to your home from anywhere so
if you know the guy from the store drops
off a package there in early Christmas
present or your mother-in-law shows up
unannounced to bring over who knows what
you will be able to see here and speak
to them all from your phone and if it's
your mother-in-law you can just stand in
place really quietly and not keep the
lights off and just hope that nothing
happens if you're on the go this season
whether it's across town or whether it's
across the country you can check in
anytime for some much-needed holiday
peace of mind I love my ring doorbell I
just feel safe especially when I go on
the road you know sweet little lease is
a pretty good shot but it's nice that
you can be able to check in I also give
out ring as a housewarming gift to my
friends so like for instance we've got
one friend of mine they just bought a
house this was a few months ago I give
them a ring doorbell and this is a new
neighborhood they were a little nervous
they heard things going on outside they
checked their ring device because it
uploads straight to the cloud they see
was just a possible just a cute little
possum man they like the possum if it
were me I probably would have taken that
that good old firearm that I've
outfitted sweet little Lisa with and
going out and taking care of the possum
they're nicer people than me ring will
give you peace of mind as a listener you
have a special holiday offer on a ring
starter kit available right now with a
ring video doorbell - and
motion-activated floodlight camera the
starter kit has everything you need to
start building a ring of security around
your home no matter what this holiday
season brings by the way I would suggest
rig is a great Christmas present because
it's so cool it's so impressive it's so
helpful and the price is really really
good so you'll get a lot of credit for a
great great gift but you don't want it
you won't have to shell out an
exorbitant amount of money with ring
you're always home just go to ring.com
slash Knolls cana wles ring.com slash
Noel's came to wles additional terms may
apply so there is at least one clip
there's not at least one there's at most
one clip yesterday from the testimony
that Democrats are hanging their hats on
and saying see there's evidence of a
quid pro quo we got to throw the
president out of office here it is
secretary Perry ambassador will
and I worked with mr. Rudy Guiliani on
Ukraine matters at the express direction
of the President of the United States we
did not want to work with mr. Giuliani
simply put we were playing the hand we
were dealt we all understood that if we
refused to work with mr. Giuliani we
would lose a very important opportunity
to cement relations between the United
States and Ukraine so we followed the
president's orders
there it is we followed the president's
orders they worked with mr. Giuliani
they followed the president's orders
they didn't want to work with mr.
Giuliani but they did so what's the
problem here the the implication what
Adam Schiff is using to say that there
was a basic quid pro quo is that the
employees of the federal government the
diplomats were forced to work with the
president's personal lawyer
therefore the president obviously had a
personal interest in getting Ukraine to
investigate Joe Biden therefore this is
evidence in and of itself of a quid pro
quo okay when we're talking about the
role of Rudy Giuliani here I think it's
perfectly valid to raise the question
why is the president sending his
personal lawyer here that's perfectly
valid obviously he's got an interest in
it when we're talking about the role of
Rudy Giuliani through Joe Biden being
investigated I think it's perfectly
valid to say an investigation of Joe
Biden could potentially give some help
to Donald Trump now I'm not totally
convinced of that because I don't think
Joe Biden is anywhere near the actual
front-runner in this race for the
Democratic primary I don't think there's
a very good chance that Joe Biden is
gonna get the nomination anyway so I
don't think it would provide Trump a lot
of help but let's just go with all of
that compare that information to what
we've seen in the past not just two
weeks not just two years but really
since Trump started running for office
there is a concerted effort in the
Federal Bureau
see the deep state to undermine the
president's policy agenda you heard
Lieutenant Colonel Vin de Minh yesterday
say that he's vind Minh is the one who
makes policy the interagency makes
policy and the president better just go
along with it and if the president's not
gonna go along with it we're gonna throw
them out of office so you've got this
this attempted coup that's been going on
for three years to overturn the
presidential election and overturn the
policies of the President of the United
States duly elected don't you think it
makes sense the president Trump would
put his own his own guys in there just
to oversee things to make sure that
everything's going all right to me that
makes perfect sense now is that is that
how the government should operate no but
should the deep state bureaucrats also
be overturning the policies of the
president United States I don't think so
I don't think that should be happening
at all now even further if you want the
absolute end of it all Sunland says look
that there was no quid pro quo I was
told not to engage in a quid pro quo but
I was told to work with Giuliani and
that's sort of a quid pro quo
if if that's an issue here
why did Sunland not clarify all of this
in his opening statement if there is any
question at all of improper conduct of a
quid pro quo
why did ambassador Salman not put it in
his 23 page opening statement and just
say hey by the way guys I did have a
conversation with Trump he told me not
to engage in a quid pro quo Jim Jordan
nails him on it why didn't you put that
statement in your opening statement I
think you said you couldn't fit it in is
that right say we might be here for 46
minutes and it wasn't five my son's
purposeful trust me
wasn't purposeful no couldn't fit it in
a 23-page opener the most important
statement about the subject matter at
hand the president unites in a direct
conversation with you about the issue at
hand and the president says let me read
it one more time what do you want from
Ukraine mr. president I want nothing I
want no quid pro quo I want this new guy
brand new guy in politics his party
just took over I won Solinsky to do the
right thing I want him to run on and do
what he ran on which is deal with
corruption and you can't find time to
fit that in a 23-page opening statement
okay this this line of sawn ones so that
he just didn't have time you know he was
busy had to go run to the gym or
something so he didn't have time to put
that in there that doesn't make a whole
lot of sense what I suspect here and
again this is pure conjecture is that
Sandlin didn't like the idea that he had
to work with rudy giuliani maybe he
didn't like the way that the Ukraine
issue was being handled maybe the
Ukraine issue wasn't being handled in
the same way as is traditional as as you
would see in typical State Department
policy and so he's pushing back against
the policy I think that's what's getting
at the heart of it here when you're
talking about the left-right divide when
you're talking about the bureaucracy
versus elected divide I think you are
getting down to an argument about policy
and some people don't like the way that
the president is conducting policy all
right too bad you can run for president
and then you can get elected you can
have whatever policy you want the
American people need to be able to run
their own government and the American
people run their government through
their duly elected representatives not
through bureaucrats not even through the
appointed guys if there were evidence
that the president committed an
impeachable offense here I think we
would have heard it I think we would
have heard it by now after what the
fifth or sixth star key witness but
instead what we heard from Sunland
exonerates the president this should be
the end of impeachment and yet I
guarantee you it's going to go on and on
and on it's actually fine by me I think
this helps Trump in the 2020 election I
think the debate last night among the
Democrats helps Trump in the 2020
election I think they want this to
continue to go on because the more this
impeachment charade goes on the more
that Democrats are showing you they have
nothing to run on in 2020 and the more
the federal bureaucracy is showing their
cards fine by me
we have got to get to the debate by the
way absolutely disastrous
Joe Biden before we do that though I've
got to thank our friends over at zip
recruiter it could you imagine oh if
only we can apply zip recruiter to our
political elections our presidential
election then maybe we'd get some really
good candidates out there but
unfortunately we're not able to do that
but you can apply to your business cafe
alturas Co odilon biscuits needed to
hire a director of coffee for his
organic coffee company but he was having
trouble finding qualified applicants so
what did he do he switched to zip
recruiter zip recruiter doesn't depend
on candidates finding you it finds them
for you it's technology identifies
people with the right experience and
invites them to apply to your job so you
get qualified candidates fast dylan
posted his job on zip recruiter and said
he was very impressed by how quickly he
had great candidates apply go say it's
not just like throwing spaghetti at the
wall goes out there brings candidates to
you because he used SIPP recruiters
candidate rating feature to filter his
applicants he could then focus on the
most relevant ones that's that Dylan
found his a new director of coffee in
just a few days I guess if we were to
apply this to politics we'd find the
director of coffe FA but you can't do
the eou
let's be happy that you can at least
apply it to your own business with
results like that it's no wonder than
four out of five employers who post on a
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day you know one of the
main ways that the Daily wire has been
able to grow is because we have the
ability to find the right people and
it's hard it's hard to find the right
people especially when you're in an
industry such as ours in a city such as
ours luckily we have zip recruit or C Y
zip recruiters effective for businesses
of all sizes zip recruiter you can try
it now right now for free at our web
address if recruiter dot-com / Knowles
km wles that is zip recruiter dot-com /
Knowles Canada wles and make sure when
you go to try it for free you type in
zip recruiter comm slash Knowles because
we don't want to let your Pierrot get
all the credit zip recruiter the
smartest way to hire you got the whole
charade on impeachment basically a
distraction to try to hurt Trump in 2020
then you've got the affirmative case for
Democrats being made at the Democratic
presidential primary debates a sort of
frontrunner erstwhile front runner job
I'm collapsing onstage not quite
literally almost literally he had
nothing so Biden opens up the debate
making the case his case for the
presidency as has it has always been is
that Joe Biden is the most electable Joe
Biden is the most appealing Joe Biden is
the best candidate to beat Trump
unfortunately he was barely able to get
the words out next president on States
not to do same to two things defeat
Donald Trump that's number one and
number two it's gonna have to be able to
go into states like Georgia and North
Carolina and other places and get us and
a majority that's what I'll do now you
have to ask yourself up here who is most
likely to be able to win the nomination
in the first place you have to win the
presidency in the first place okay I
would suggest humbly respectfully the
candidate most likely to get the
nomination in the first place and then
beat Donald Trump is going to be the
candidate who could form a coherent
English sentence and Joe Biden can't do
that I don't know whether it's because
of his age that's what people are
blaming it on he's also just kind of a
doofus and has been a doofus for his
whole political career as early as the
80s you can't blame the age in 1988 when
Biden was still a young man so the whole
argument saying look I'm the most
electable candidate it only works if you
can speak it only works if you have any
energy on the campaign trail it only
works if you can actually make your case
Joe Biden was not able to do that when
he could speak it was even worse than
when he couldn't speak Joe Biden was
asked a question about domestic abuse
what we're gonna do about domestic abuse
women getting beaten by their husbands
in America I kid you not his answer was
he was gonna punch the issue hard and
hard and hard if you turned that in to a
Hollywood producer and said this is the
this is the script if you turned it into
Lorne Michaels you're writing for
Saturday Night Live and said this is my
impression of Joe Biden they'd say
that's so ridiculous we're not even
going to use that and yet here is Joe
Biden himself saying he is going to
viciously beat the issue of domestic
violence until it's a submissive
no man has a right to raise the hand to
a woman in anger other than in
self-defense and that's rarely ever
occurs and so we have to just change the
culture period and keep punching at it
and punching at it and punch that it
will be a Bigfoot what I really mean
it's a gigantic issue uh what are you
doing what we need to change the culture
that's the only way we're gonna stop
domestic violence we need to change the
culture and the way we're gonna change
the culture is we're gonna viciously
beat that culture we are not going to
talk to it reasonably or respectfully
we're just gonna punch it we're gonna
punch it until it does what we tell it
to do punch is gonna punch at it we're
gonna punch at it and we're gonna punch
at it uh awful awful and he actually
enjoys defense went into the debate with
a serious handicap which is he got
bombshell news about three hours before
the debate that his son Hunter Biden had
fathered a child out of wedlock with a
26 year old woman in Arkansas I believe
a DNA testing established with
scientific certainty that hunter Biden
is the father of an Arkansas baby this
is according to court papers in in
Arkansas hunter Biden had met this young
woman who London Alexis Roberts while
she was a student at George Washington
University while Hunter Biden was dating
his late brother's widow and while
hunter Biden was still not divorced from
his own wife now why does this matter am
I just mentioning this to point out what
an absolute degenerate hunter Biden is
partially but that's not the only reason
I'm mentioning this because hunter Biden
a guy who squandered his family's money
on hookers and drugs and strip clubs
that's according to divorce papers
hunter Biden who while he was still
married to his wife began sleeping with
his dead brother's widow hunter Biden
who while he was doing both of those
things also fathered a child out of
wedlock with a 26-year old student at GW
hunter Biden who went
a coke-fueled drunk drive from los
angeles after a getting into a fight at
an LA nightclub all the way to Arizona
they find a crack pipe in his car and
the cops don't press charges that guy
managed to land a position making
$600,000 a year on a Ukrainian energy
company board the whole story
just underscores how crooked this deal
was with hunter Biden in Ukraine and Joe
Biden knew about it and Joe Biden said
you better know what you're doing this
has been a major hit for the Biden
campaign it's been the impeachment story
has been a major hit for the Biden
campaign you know the it actually all
relates to impeachment because
ambassador Sandlin was asked by this
congressman Sean Patrick Maloney
Democrat who actually no I worked on a
campaign against him back in olden years
Shaun Maloney pretty good politician
little oily little unctuous but he is
very good at being a politician it's
about the worst thing you can say about
somebody Sean Patrick Maloney asks
Gordon Sunland he said who would have
been helped by a Ukrainian investigation
into Joe Biden and Sandlin is expected
to say and he does say eventually that
this would help Trump I don't know that
it helps Trump I think Joe Biden is
doing a good enough job destroying his
campaign on his own I don't think an
investigation would really help them
that much I think Joe Biden's campaign
is intrinsically flawed and his other
candidates on the stage the other
Democrats actually had a pretty good
night at Joe's expense we'll get to that
in a second we'll get to a like so
excited I'm throwing things all over the
studio here we'll get to a story about a
trans gender policy in a school district
that is making a young girl cry we'll
get to all of that and the mailbag but
first I've got to thank a new sponsor
the new sponsor is route insurance what
is the premise of route insurance it's a
very basic one right now good drivers
have to subsidize bad drivers that's how
car insurance works traditionally and
that doesn't seem very fair especially
if you're a good driver
well what if good drivers did not have
to pay for bed
drivers route insurance thinks the old
way of pricing car insurance is unfair
so they developed a mobile app that
measures driving behavior what I love
about this is it's just using new
technology in a way that can help save
you money they're bringing a new way of
thinking about car insurance to the
market so they take bad drivers out of
the equation and therefore route saves
good drivers up to 52 percent in twenty
nineteen fifty two percent off car
insurance imagine if you could save that
it is the fastest-growing direct
insurance company in the United States
route is the world's first mobile first
car insurance company they base their
rates primarily on how you drive not who
you are so look if I'm if you're a
terrible driver and you're listening to
this I guess you should tune out but if
you're a good driver then think about
this as a way that you could save more
than half on your car insurance route
insurance card will be available right
from your phone and if you get into an
accident you can file a claim directly
in the app not all that crazy hassle not
crazy paperwork that you are you used to
it makes a whole lot of sense all you
have to do is download the route
insurance app Drive normally for a few
weeks during the route test drive and
see how much you can save give a route a
try go to the App Store download the
route insurance app right now sign up in
less than a minute to start your test
drive today
that is our o o T again download the
route app today or visit join route
dot-com to learn more and see how you
could save root reserves the right to
refuse to quote any individual premium
rate for the insurance advertised here
and the savings based on national
reviews reported by actual customers not
available in all states this product is
unfortunately not to California for me
but whenever I get out of this
godforsaken state then I get to use
route and I get to save a lot of money
okay Joe Biden had a very bad night
Elizabeth Warren had a pretty good night
but even she wasn't so great she is now
pushing her wealth tax where she wants
to steal money from millionaires but she
won't admit that she's trying to steal
money from billionaires she is saying
look according to my health care plan
the way I'm gonna pay for this 52
trillion dollar plan
I just want billionaires to contribute
just a couple cents just give up a
couple
and we'll be able to pay for everything
there she is I have proposed a two-cent
wealth tax that is a tax for everybody
who has more than 50 billion dollars in
assets your first 50 billion is free and
clear
but your fifty billion that first dollar
you got a pitch in two cents and when
you hit a billion dollars you got a
pitch in a few pennies more two cents -
it's just two cents right she uses that
word throughout the debate two cents I
don't think she knows what the word cent
means what she's saying is there will be
a two percent wealth tax she also keeps
confusing millionaires and billionaires
in there but two cents is not two cents
when you're talking about say a billion
dollars two senses twenty million
dollars every single year and what's
difficult about this is that people
don't just keep piles of cash what they
do is they have their money in different
investments so what you could get into a
situation here is that these
millionaires and billionaires have to
start liquidating their assets actually
selling off their assets just to pay the
government which has come in to their
door with a gun in their hands and
saying give us your money stick them up
the trouble is also you've got a
fifty-two trillion dollar health plan
Liz Warren is pushing the total combined
wealth of every billionaire in the
United States there's 621 of them the
combined wealth is like three point
three trillion dollars something like
that so you could confiscate all their
wealth take the shirt off their back you
wouldn't be able to pay for one year of
Liz Warren's health plan you'd get
through a 65% of one year then what then
what do you do it's not just two cents
you've already taken all their money now
what are you supposed to do obviously
those taxes are gonna hit the middle
class
she had a relatively fine night she
didn't really improve but she's she's a
decent candidate compared to the other
jokers on the stage Cory Booker had an
OK night he did better than he usually
does still probably not going anywhere
Pete Budaj edge had a very strong night
he didn't make too many mistakes he got
into a fight with Tulsi Gabbard and
basically won it he's moving up the
polls in Iowa he's moving up the polls
in New Hampshire he said a while ago
that the race was gonna come down to
Budaj and Warren I think there's a fair
chance he might be right we will get to
a really disturbing story about
transgenderism we will get to the
mailbag but first I've got to thank our
friends over at the Daily wire daily
wire 10 bucks a month hundred dollars
for an annual membership you get me at
the Andrew Klavan show you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get to that wall show
you get to ask questions and mailbag
coming up you get another Kingdom and by
the way if you're craving more of my
soothing sultry voice then you haven't
been listening to another Kingdom Andrew
clavin's fantasy podcast third and final
season performed by me you need to go to
Daley wire.com subscribe right now
because on Monday November 25th at 7
p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific drew and I
will be sitting down together to discuss
this final season we will take
subscriber questions alive from the fans
this live event will be free for
everyone to watch on Facebook and
YouTube but only subscribers will be
able to ask the questions at daily
wire.com so you can listen to this
newest season on Apple podcasts go check
it out don't miss another Kingdom live
discussion Monday at 7 p.m. Eastern 4
p.m. Pacific go to daily wire.com we'll
be right back with a lot more
really disturbing story coming out of
Palatine High School in Northwest
Illinois board members voted to give
unrestricted locker room and restroom
access to transgender students the board
voted this way in a meeting attended by
500 people why did they do this because
a transgender student meaning a boy
pretending to be a girl he identifies as
a as nova May Day that's his name that
he created he filed one of two lawsuits
against the high school in 2017 we
actually have some video of the scene
after the vote was taken this young man
was all smiles grinning ear-to-ear so
happy that he will now be able to go
into the girls locker room and the
school will now force young girls to
undress in front of this ma'am in front
of this post-pubescent man you get the
video of him gloating about it and you
get a video of a girl crying because she
will now be forced to get naked in front
of boys in her school this is where
transgenderism ideology has a lead check
it out I'm really hoping they vote for
it it's something to be a a step forward
in progress I'm I'm
really excited if they vote for it a bit
nervous though as as always just you
never know but it's definitely first
step forward in in many more steps it's
a great policy unfortunately it's not
everything we want such as talking about
even even the small things like changing
the name on your student ID which you're
required to wear at all times so I'm
really hoping that the district makes
the right decision here in folks yeah I
passed it passed
and how does that make you feel I mean
I'm ecstatic
my privacy invading multiple times this
is so profoundly screwed up this is so
disturbing this is exactly what we all
predicted we talked about this yesterday
conservatives always predict what will
happen on the so-called slippery slope
and then leftists tell us that we're
just hysterical we're crazy it's not
going to happen and then it happens and
they say oh come on get over it's no big
deal
men should not be allowed into the girls
locker room girls should not be forced
to get naked in front of men this is a
fact this is simple enough this is a
gross miscarriage of justice that's
going on at this high school so much for
feminism and I don't I don't even like
feminism so much for traditional social
norms so much for chivalry the age of
chivalry really is gone when a man is
gonna force his way in to watch women
get naked in a locker room adults are
permitting this adults are enforcing
this all of these adults on the school
board who and the school administrators
have pushed for this all of them should
lose their jobs all of them should be
ostracized from polite society this is
profoundly wrong the law is clearly
moving in this direction because leftism
is advancing so-called social justice
there's no actual justice here there's
only injustice we must push back against
this through all social means that we
possibly can what has happened here is
horrible every school board member
should be absolutely
deprived of belonging to polite society
all of them they should they should not
be permitted in polite society we need
to keep up the pressure campaign what
the left wants to do is just say look we
got it we got this win here we got this
win there go along it's okay
be inclusive be nice be tolerant no
don't give up on this issue this issue
this is outrageous what's going on these
issues are going to make it up to the
Supreme Court we need to make sure that
when it does get up to the Supreme Court
we've already got a few cases like it at
the court that the right decision comes
out the court follows public opinion the
court pays attention to elections the
court looks at the protests that are
going out outside the court house on
those very days if you adhere to this
gender ideology then you are forcing
young girls to get naked in front of
post-pubescent men in locker rooms and
every one of those tears that those
little girls are crying justifiably so
is on you alright let's get to the
mailbag first question from Ashley
Michael if you could construct an ark to
preserve man's greatest works of art and
literature what would be the first three
things that you would put in there after
the Bible I would put in Shakespeare I
would put in Dante and I would put in
Homer those would be the first three
works of art and literature I would put
in other way if we were including
philosophy and nonfiction works and
histories I would put in other works but
Shakespeare Dante and Homer by the way
if you read those three things you will
have a very good sense of of Western
literature from Bryce Michael how do you
distinguish between patriotism and
jingoism what can conservatives with
temperance do to balance the love of
country with mindless crowd think by
jingoism here you mean this extreme
excessive patriotism another word that
could be used for this as chauvinism
there's a big difference between love of
country and chauvinism or jingoism
chauvinism comes from a real person or
at least a real apocryphal story I know
that sounds like a contradiction in
terms but from a person that French
people believed was real though he might
have just been a legend Nicholas Siobhan
they believe he was born around 1780 he
enlisted in the military at age 18 he
served honorably he was wounded 17 times
in the service of his nation he didn't
care they're blown off his limbs he's
gonna go back out there and fight and he
had severe disfigurement and maiming but
he loved his country so much and the
story goes for his loyalty and service
Napoleon himself gave the soldier the
saber of Honor and a pension of two
hundred francs did this really happen
we're not sure but the story of it is
this story of excessive love of
countries sort of single-minded love of
country you don't want that you love of
country is a beautiful thing and this
would typically today be referred to as
nationalism but I don't even really use
that term so much I just think love of
countries justify just like you love
your father you love your mother and you
love your community so too do you love
your family but you should not ground
your identity primarily in your country
you need to you can't ground your
identity in anything that is merely
temporal and ephemeral you've got to
grab your your identity ultimately in
something metaphysical ultimately in God
who is the source and summit of all
identity if you do that then all those
other natural loves will follow natural
love of country natural of a family
natural love of everything if you try to
ground your identity in something
ephemeral it's going to pervert all of
those other identities and you're gonna
get bizarre extreme obsessiveness like
jingoism and chauvinism from jasmine
hello Michael I saw the men's conference
panel that you were on this is a
reference to whose panel was that so the
gosh his name escapes me we were on I
was on a men's panel with a a moderator
I totally forgot his name well I'll
remember it right after the show is over
and I'll tweet it out he said Oh Jesse
Peterson thankful okay good I finally
came to meet Jesse Jesse Peterson good
friend of mine little eccentric
character but I liked him he asked if it
was not for sex would men have anything
to do with women the letter goes on you
and most of the other panelists all said
no a few reasons were given in
beauty and procreation as a woman I was
put off to say the least
if there are the only benefits to women
what Pointer purpose are left for the
ugly or fat women or women unable to
bear children I look forward to your
response Thanks
I did not say no I'll go back and look
at the tape but I believe what I said
was that if not for sex differences
there would be no such thing as women
which is a very different answer if
Jessie's question was if not for sex
would you have anything to do with women
my answer is if not for sex there would
not be women what is a woman a woman is
sexually complementary to a man the
reason that there is a difference
between men and women is because there
is a sexual difference between men and
women so the question if mount for sex
would you have anything to do with women
is a nonsensical question it's like
saying if there were no women would you
have anything to do with women
I guess not because there wouldn't be
women then everyone would just be the
same category which we could call either
men or women but there wouldn't be both
so that is my answer now obviously I'm
not just talking about physical sex I'm
just talking about you know that fun
thing that people do at night I'm
talking about everything else that flows
from sexual difference our personality
differences our domestic differences the
way that with the men and women
complement each other from the very
beginning of time I totally stand by
that answer and I think so much of
gender ideology today it stems from a
misunderstanding of the fact of sexual
difference the confusion about marriage
stems from a misunderstanding of the
fact that sexual difference is essential
to human life within the first few
chapters of Genesis you see the
importance of that sexual difference and
that's a wonderful thing not to be
resented but to be celebrated and I
certainly celebrated from Ty hello
Michael do you think another kingdom
would translate well to the silver
screen or if it would require too many
special effects for the amazing scenes
within and would you be willing to play
Austin Lively if the role were offered
to you or do you have anyone you would
recommend for the roles I of course I
would play the role and I think it would
be great on the silver screen or really
in a TV adaptation drew received
a number of requests to bring this
before Hollywood especially after the
first season which was a pretty big hit
we're talking about very large
production companies trouble was once he
got into the room maybe the night before
they actually googled him and I think
because of his politics maybe because of
my politics it was basically not
seriously considered for Hollywood it's
too bad I think would be a great project
it's obviously been very very successful
as a podcast if it were created by a
left-wing novelist there is no doubt in
my mind it would already be in
development at a studio that's the way
it is in Hollywood that's why we got to
make our own stuff from Walter hi
Michael loved the show please help me
understand why so many if not all of the
roads to dismantle this once great
country always lead back to Yale
not only the actors but Yale also is the
keeper of any secrets for instance the
records from that immoral twin study
among others recently there have even
been rumors of a connection to Jeffrey
Epstein who parenthetically didn't
commit suicide I'd love to hear what you
think fair question I don't I don't
actually know the details about the
examples you mentioned but it is true
there are a lot of a lot of nefarious
things in American history that have led
back to Yale well for instance the
recent breakdown of the American
category of universities started in the
courtyard at Yale where a young girl
screamed and yelled at her professor and
and you saw that them takeover
universities around the country the
reason for this I don't think is some
great conspiracy I think it's because
Yale is very very old was one of the
first universities in the country it's
significantly older than the nation
itself and Yale has always been a sort
of elite institution it wasn't always
even the most intellectually rigorous
for a long time it was considered in
just a sort of finishing school for
gentlemen when JFK gave a speech there
he got an honorary degree and he said
now I have the two greatest things you
can have from the American Academy a
Harvard education and a Yale degree that
was sort of what he was alluding to but
it's because it's very old
and it's because it's got a reputation
as elite by the way this is why the left
has infiltrated it that's why they've
made such a point of taking over Yale so
that now you have something more
resembling zombie Yale on the outside it
basically looks the same but on the
inside it has been rotted out by leftism
doesn't only happen at Yale it happens
in so many institutions the deep state
you know the the federal bureaucracy the
left has gone into that federal
government taken so much power for
itself
rotted it out from within and so you see
a lot of conspiracies developed there I
don't know if it's exactly the fault of
the institution I think that the
institution had prestige and power and
that's why the left has gone into it and
it's not going to stop at Yale it's not
going to stop at the State Department
it's going to to the left is always
going to go into those institutions the
key for conservatives is we can't
abandon them we can't just say okay you
can have it but but we're gonna have our
own institution somewhere else the left
is gonna go for that too they're gonna
do it at the churches they're gonna do
it at your civic associations you have
got to fight back from Danny hi Michael
my boyfriend and I have been dating for
close to four years now as of late I've
been struggling with the idea of
abstinence and wonder what your thoughts
might be on walking back that part of
the relationship it might be a part of
my spiritual reawakening as cliche as I
truly know that sounds I feel like it's
important right now in our relationship
to build on stronger ties and focus on
the sexual avenues after marriage any
advice you might have on talking to my
boyfriend about this would be helpful
Thanks so what you're saying is you're
already in a sexual relationship now
you're having a spiritual reawakening
and you think it's time to dial that
back I think that's a great idea I think
it is a great idea and this is an issue
that a lot of young people are dealing
with today I told you I was an atheist
for ten years and I behaved like one
when I was an atheist a friend of mine
actually who experienced life as a
millennial does during his teenage years
and in his 20s he said a spiritual
reawakening a religious reawakening and
he's actually now dialing back what was
a fairly prodigiously of his and
attempting to be to abstain from sex
until marriage I think it's a good idea
it's kind of the opposite of what the
Boomers went through in the 60s our
parents generation was told you've got
to have a traditional sexual morality
they rebelled against that and you got
the the cult of free love
Millennials and Gen Z are seeing where
that has led us and it's led us down
some pretty dark paths and so with
Millennials and Gen Z are saying is hold
on
we should dial back the free love we
should dial it back to her traditional
morality I think that makes a whole lot
of sense and I think your boyfriend if
he's worth his salt will be amenable to
that because even men there is this
ridiculous caricature out that we're
just sort of grunting buffoons and all
we want to do is have sex all the time
maybe that's 90% true but there is a 10%
of men 10% of our inner lives that
recognize that there is a transcendent
moral order and I think that if the
women in our lives were to say hold on a
second maybe we shouldn't do this
and we would listen this has
traditionally been the role of women men
pursue women resist and then you get
married and you have a good life
together that is my advice for you and I
wish you luck and that is our show have
a good weekend I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael nul show see you Monday
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director
Pavel why douse key edited by Danny
D'Amico audio is mixed by Mike Gore
Amina hair and makeup is by Jessa alvera
and our production assistant is NIC
Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there